[موسيقى]
طب توقعاتكم واهلا وسهلا بكم في حوار
فرانس 24 ضيفتنا هي غاده ايوب النائب عن
تكتل الجمهوريه القويه في مجلس النواب
اللبناني اهلا وسهلا بك على قناه فرانس 24
اول الطريق واللي هي رئيس انقاذي سياس
السيادي وبالتالي عنده همم القدره على
الحل واداره
الازمات والحل هذه الازمات متمسكين فيه
لانه بيمثل هالمواصفات لانه اجتمعت قوى
المعارضه على هذا الاسم
يحصل على 65 سم
لانه قادر يطلع من حليفه
واعطي شرعيه للسلاح واللي هو همم جبران
غسيل ولانه قادر يتخلى كمان عن سليمان
فرجيه اللي هو بيعطيه كمان
ست سنوات مقبله فاذن بما انهم
بوضع همم
في عندنا عمل انه يكون في بعض التغييرين
والسياديين وغير يكونوا عم يرجعوا يلتفوا
مشان معود او اي مرشح يستطيع انه يتخطل 65
صوت طيب
البطريق لو دعائي لا طويله حوار مسيحي
مسيحي تشاركون فيه
الحوار سواء سواء البطرك ولا كمان رئيس
بري رئيس مجلس النواب دعى الى حوار من
داخل مجلس النواب وكانه بنغيب الدستور
اللبناني بمطرح مع عيان همم واللي هو في
اليه واضحه بالدستور اللبناني وهو يجب على
رئيس مجلس النواب ان يدعو الى جلسات
متتاليه لحين التوصل الى الانتخاب رئيس
الجمهوريه فلماذا الحوار بظل وجود اشخاص
هم رايحين على التعطيل وعندهن الراي
والقرار بانه قطع تعطيل قد يكون لمصلحتهم
لحتى ترجع تتحسن شروط وصول الى سده
الرئاسه بينما في فريق اخر واللي هو نحن
ننتمي اليه مست انه ننزلوا عم ننزل بكل
جلسه ننتخب مشعل معوض لا نعطل النصاب
وعندنا كل القدره انه نكون بقلب مجلس
النواب عم نناقش كيفيه الخروج من هذه
الازمه فاذا اليوم وقت بدك تقعد تتحاور
بدك تحاور كمان على اسس ومبادئ بيقدر
يكونوا عم بقربه
مع ذلك
الديمقراطيه واليوم بالانتخابات
هو اللي يحكم وعلى اساسه والفريق الاخر
جديد اللي هو بده بناء الدوله بناء
المؤسسات بده انه يكون في عنا زياده
محترمه ويكون في حدود غير
وشرع الى التهريب ويكون في عنا سياسي
خارجيه واضحه تحمل لبنان مثل ما قال
البترك هي بتكون تدعوا الى الحيه وبالتالي
لا نقوم همم مطالبه بمساعده المجتمع
الدولي ونحن بالمقابل منحارب باليمن
وبالعراق الدول
والتيار الوطني الحر ممكن مثل ما حصل عند
انتخاب ميشاون
غير الظروف اللي
22 هلا اكيد نحن ما رح نروح بقى على اتفاق
مع اي فريق الا اذا هو اجى على ثوابتنا
وعلى ما بدانا
لحنكون ما لحنكون بقى عم نتنازل لانه هيل
مرحله بالزيت ما بقى فيها تنازل جربنا ست
سنين رحنا الى الجحيم رحنا الى جهنم رحنا
الى مزيد من الانهيار ما بقى فينا نكمل
بذات النهج من هون نحنا بندعي كل الفراققه
واذا اليوم الطيار الوطني الحر او غيره عم
بيوعوا لخطوره حالي وانه التفاهم اللي
عمله ما حزب الله ولا مع غيره ما وصل
البلد الا الى مزيد من الاستسلام وانهيار
المؤسسات ومفهوم الدوله يمكن اذا رجعوا
على الثوابت الاساسيه لبناء الدوله سويا
اكيد نحنا بنحط ايدنا بايد الكل تنبني
دوري
نحن لا
حزب الله نحن ندعو الى تطبيق الطائف مع
القرارات الداخليه
وبالتالي ما بقى في ضروره بيكون ومبرر ليه
سلاح المقاومه واللي عم يشترته في انه
الرئيس اللي بده يجي بده يجي بشروط انه
يشرع هذا السلاح ويشرع الامر الواقع والا
هن ولا راح يرضوا بهايدر رئيس هنا نحن
عندنا نضال هالمرحله اللي بتشبه مرحله ال
75 واللي هي لكن نضال سياسي نضال
بالمؤسسات لحتى نقدر نقول له لا ما بقى
فينا نشرع الواقع وبالتالي السماح لحزب
الله بانه يدله مسيطر على كيفه المؤسسات
والتهديد بالفراغ لحتى اروح على استسلام
وان كان سنه او سنتين لن نعود الى الوراء
وبعتقد انه صار في وعي كامل والمجتمع
الدولي كمان ندعوا الى تطبيق هذه القرارات
الدوليه الى المطالبه بتطبيق اتفاق الطائف
واللي هو بيرجع حزب الله الى همم حضن
الدوله اللبنانيه واذا قرر انه يترك هذه
المعارك اللي بيخوذه خارج لبنان وان يكون
فقط ك همم وسيله بيد ايران ولا غيره همم
يمكن بمطرح معين فينا نروح على بناء دوله
لكن اذا هو مصر على استعمال الساحه
اللبنانيه لتمرير الرسائل ولتقويت مصالح
ايران على حساب الدوله اللبناني بعد ان هم
راح يكون في مشكل بوصول رئيس جمهوريه بني
ادم طيب ما هو تقييمكم لاداء عهد عوني
منه بحاجه نحنا نعمل تقييم لعهد عون لانه
بعتقد انه ست سنوات اوصلت لبنان الى اكبر
ازمه اقتصاديه
سياسيه نقديه ما مرق فيها بتاريخ جديد
وعندك حليفك اللي هو همم دعمك بسلاح
ويعطيك الغطاء انك انت ما تقدر
ولا تقدر انك تكون عندك اي رؤيه لا تدعيم
هذه المؤسسات انما كان اكثر هو التسليم
وهذا المقايضه ما بقى مسموحه واللي هي نحن
بنوصلك على السلطه وانت بتغطى لنا سلاحنا
هيدا المقايضه خلصت من نتيجه الانتخابات
النيابيه اللي حصلت اخيرا واللي فيها همم
اصبحت الكويت اللبنانيه انتزعت اكبر قوه
مسيحيه موجوده
بالبرلماني بيبي 19 نائب وبالتالي لازم
نسمع للانتخابات النيابيه ومنكون عم نعمل
مثل انقلاب على الدستور وهذه النتيجه لازم
تتكرس بوجود رئيس وحكومه وايه مجلس نواب
متكامل رايح على قيام الدوله وبناء الدوله
وليس الى فريق اخر يسلم الدولي الى
الدويلي وبتسيلي يقوم بمزيد من ضرب اسس
السيادي اللبنانيه
من الاشتراك ومن
حزب التجدد وبعد التغييرين او السيادي
الوقت انه نبدا دوله
من دون وجود رئيس جمهوريه انقاذي ما بقى
فينا نكمل ما بقى في لبنان وهويه لبنان
بالنسبه لكن احنا واضحين بمعاييرنا واضحين
واضحين بيساوى بيتنا ومش عم نعمل مفاوض
ولا همم عمليه همم يعني مقايضه لحتى ناخذ
سلطه انما لا ولو كنا عم نكون بدنا رئيس
من اكبر تكتل مسيحي مثل ما كان قبل عم
تنطر هذه كنا رشحنا الدكتور سمير جعشا لكن
احنا كرمال المصلحه الوطنيه الكبرى رحنا
على خيار انه شو بتتوافق هو المعارضه نحن
بنمشي معه تنوصل لرئيس لانه اليوم هي اهم
مرحله انه نقدر نخلص لبنان وشبابه من
الازم اللي نحن فيه
يمكن ان تفرز مشهدا سياسيا جديدا في لبنان
مثل ما الانتخابات النيابيه قدرت انها
توصل على القليله لتنتهي
تنتزع الاكتيريه من يتخط الممانعه انا
باعتقد انه في واعي كيف ده حتى اذا انتجنا
صرت جديده انه نكمل بهايد المسار نحو بناء
الدوله
يا سيدي اذا بنشوف اذا بنشوف اليوم الواقع
الصغير اللي عم يشوفه بالجامعات اللي
موجوده في لبنان النتيجه صادمه للي كانوا
متوقعين انه ما راح يصير في اي تغيير اذا
الشباب الجامع قال لبناني يعطي وياخذ همم
المبادره لاعطاء الاولويه لخط السياده لخط
اللي هو مع ال ااه ضد الدويلي وضد يعني مع
بناء الدوله فاذا نقدر نشوف انه التغيير
ولبنان اللي احنا نؤمن انه لازم يكون
موجود وداله ويرجع مناره
انه صار الوقت انه يرجع الشباب تقريبا
ما وصلنا اليه لكن فعليا هذا الامر فقط من
بعد مقوله كلهم يعني اللون سقطت بالواقع
اللي انا شفنا انه الناس اللي هي في بعض
الناس تمت عمه اللي اخدوا هذا الشعار
كانوا هن اليوم من ابرز المعطلين
وبالنهايه ما قدروا يوصلوا انه يتفقوا على
مرشح وسبته انه الاحزاب اللي عندها قضيه
واللي عندها هويه واللي عندها مبادئ
وسوابت مثل القوات اللبنانيه قادره انها
توصل وتوصل صوت للمجلس النيابي ومن بعد
تكون عم تكون هذه المعركه اللي هي سياديه
بامتياز وليست معركه همم مسيحيه فقط وهنا
بحب اقول انه اليوم معركه رئاسه الجمهوريه
هي معركه كل اللبنانيين اللي بدهم لبنان
بيشبههن يقدروا يكونوا يكملوا فيه غدا يوم
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا